alright y'all it's time for my first
guest she is a perfect example of why
you should never give up
she's persevered through almost a decade
of rejection in Hollywood and music now
she's starring on one of the biggest
shows on TV a this is us and last year a
song she sang was nominated for an Oscar
this year she releases her first album
of country music and I cannot wait to
hear it I love her let's all say hi to
Chrissie meds
what's up Chrissie how you doing what
are you I am so good lovely to see you
by the way you look beautiful I love you
in a ponytail listen thank you I got
about two hairstyles it's up sometimes
straight down okay here's mine this is
mine when it doesn't work like I curled
my hair this morning and it just was
like what the hell is happening so I
just pin it back that's what I just pin
it back at home I went for this I didn't
it's a great hair and makeup well you're
kind
I understand you've been holding it down
in one of my favorite cities in
Nashville I am since the beginning of
March
yeah oh yes were you there like working
and then just kind of were like okay I'm
stuck here no we came out to finish the
back half of my album yeah yeah oh yeah
and then the record just stops literally
and so yeah we've been here Donnie and I
just was inspecting goodness I happen
here but oh my god right yeah I wouldn't
I know I have friends and I sometimes
get jealous of when they're like at home
alone without children but because the
most part I think four months that would
have I would have gone insane I have to
be around at least one human right so so
it is you and your best friend Donny
right but y'all been y'all been finding
ways to stay busy
I need you to tell us about these
tetherball battles and I love that
you're playing tetherball because that's
like my childhood right third grade I
was what can we do in the confines of
the backyard
I got a regulation tetherball folks is
what I did from the internet because I
was like Donny let's play well he's not
very versed on two other wall I am
however and I'm also super competitive
which is obnoxious let's just say I had
this thing key won't go all the way now
I have jammed this pinkie and I can't I
don't know what's happened guys so
Donnie starts kicking the ball and I'm
started like you know it got competitive
got low heated so I what I was the same
way but you know every kid that grew up
not in like the richest neighborhood if
you know what tetherball is like I'm
like that was like a cheap thing to have
on the playground for all of us so I
love to other I think it's amazing well
congratulations on your recent music
deal by the way that's really cool the
first song you released is called
talking to God so what's that about
so that was found on a national bread
writers retreat and I mean he's great I
know they knew all the writers on the
retreat and I my manager was like oh you
know they wrote this on this week and
I'm like wow tear it and I just fell in
love with it it was one of those songs
where I didn't write and didn't have any
any sort of you know time spent on the
song but I just was connected yeah it
just it felt so important to me and and
I get it that like you know we all make
decisions or wish we made it would have
made different decisions and we all
think about me before no lives anymore
and you know it just resonated with me
sounds like I want to cut it can I
please so and and I mean we've touched
on this a little in the past with you
but isn't it true that you didn't want
to sing as a child like you wanted to be
in a band well no no I wanted to say
that's what I want to do I really wanted
to sing but I was too afraid of my own
shadow and because because my mom
couldn't afford an instrument in all the
cool kids were in band yeah oh so join
choir because it's free you know and
there that's me right I'm like okay
right and so he felt really comfortable
to be one of many but you don't
understand like the blending and the
technique and all that stuff and that
was really super fun and important and
that's really where I got like I mean I
always had a love for music cuz I grew
up with it but actually doing it you
know and the safety of a choir was yeah
beginning I always loved like growing up
in a choir as well like and that
around it and I was too poor to play I
couldn't be in band either cuz we didn't
have money but and this was free so I
get you up there honestly being in that
choir being in those around those
personalities a kid that we're all just
oddballs like very nerdy like you know
none of us were cool and we just we're
just figuring out our own personalities
I think that really helps so I I I love
that you you'd love to sing and you were
like well I just didn't want to be in
the spotlight yet so yeah that's knowing
that is amazing to about yourself so
Chrissy the five most recent episodes of
this is a start streaming on peacock TV
today which is awesome because all these
streaming services are really bringing
new life to show star you're all excited
about that yeah absolutely I think you
know a lot of people don't necessarily
have the time or didn't have the time
and now they have the time or have the
ability to even access it so yeah you're
right though there is so many people in
this world that haven't seen it even
though it's an international show that's
right and if you can make things
convenient for people I think they're
more inclined to watch it and then
they're like hooked because it's just
such a real raw you know yeah I'm
excited about the peacock thing because
I like to all these shows that like
could make a really big impact on people
that just didn't know they were even
never gonna get to see it so yeah so how
have you been keeping up speaking of
this is us do you all have I know that
you get in these casts especially to
these really successful Angelia on their
four seasons like have y'all been able
to catch up at all if y'all zoomed at
all or doesn't yes oh we have done we
have zoomed and and it was so sweet
because Justin Hartley who plays Kevin
is like he's the one that's like hey
guys do you wanna zoom and we're like oh
and that's Justin like he's not just
like a handsome guy who's super talented
like he has the biggest heart and so so
cute that he's the one that wanted to
arrange it so and then Chris arranged
you know the actual appointment time and
called it the Miguel Rivas fan club yeah
Jon Huertas plays Miguel yeah and
everyone always like no one likes Miguel
jon is the best Gordon got it all
because everybody just you know makes a
joke about it but yeah it's
fine we just get to sort of see each
other which is nice it's like the phone
calls aren't quite enough in the text
chats or no getting to see each other
like any kind of Zoomer FaceTime or I
agree I mean can you imagine what this
would be like without it without seeing
people like in adjust on a phone like
you know in my kitchen with like Rosanna
phone line that's like 10 feet long you
know that would kill me that's for sure
so grateful for technology yeah no no me
too
so who have your this is s Cass seemed
to be having the best time in quarantine
like when y'all talked who's like living
their best life I think really me I have
to be honest I really like being at home
I mean you don't have kids right now so
that's oh there you go that's why you
know what I'm telling you that you're
having the best time I don't know about
everybody else with a love I love
actually getting to have the time I'm
especially like you know recent I've
been waking up every morning and
coloring with them and it's like a lot
of kind of me time with them and I've
loved that but at the same time it's
like oh my gosh I really want to go to a
dinner with adults and just talk about
adult things so yeah I mean I feel sure
sterling because he and Ryan he and his
wife are you know obviously teaching
their two sons and he's like man so I
got I got a run guys I got I got a start
class I got to do this we got to do that
and I know I don't I don't listen I can
barely keep a succulent alive but I
started my favorite Cuban all right well
there's something else that I thought
was kind of cool that you're doing so
you have it's a new line at Walmart
right a new clothing line yeah brand I
know you know it's funny I was um when I
was at home I drove by the Walmart that
my mom and I had to like walk to because
my mom's car didn't work I mean you know
and it was super far I mean it felt like
10 miles I think there's only four but
regardless I was like oh my gosh I have
this partnership with a brand that I've
been you know literally shopping at for
yeah when I was a young kid I tried a
little girl like they didn't have cute
clothes like there weren't cute girl
clothes for chubby girls or for any
anybody that was sort of outside of a
straight size just generally and now
that they are incorporating such
incredible it's like affordable but it's
also trendy and I think that's really
important kind of people you feel then
we do good and all of that it's all sort
of encompassing and so when I you know
was even approached by my mom and I was
like oh well yeah like this makes sense
for me because it's something that I
think it's just um I think it's real
that's what I like it's believable it's
like I'm just a girl I shop there -
growing up and it's I think you know for
some people they hear like oh well you
don't need to be trendy like that's not
important it's like you don't realize
how important that is unless you don't
fit in that circle you don't realize how
devastating that is for a kids are like
you know even me I grew up you know with
payless shoes and everybody else had
Nikes and it was like my shoes were the
ones I made black marks all over the
basketball court and it's and those kind
of things
counts and that really does you know you
start recognizing your life and your
being is like less than and I think that
it's really important and awesome that
they reached out to you because you
represent a lot of the American
community and the world community and so
I think it's really important that when
you when any of us do like these sponsor
things or or these endorsements or these
deals that it's believable and it's real
and that's what I really loved about it
so thank you for doing it it's cool I'm
super grateful and it's it's funny how
you know life happens and how it oh hold
and I'm like oh I would never thought
you know a girl struggling in games
before I would you know have sort of a
really important partnership with yeah
and and can create such an impact for
other little girls in Gainesville that
are going through the same thing so
that's the coolest thing we're able to
do with whatever you want to call this
our little version of superpower so but
thank you so much Christy I always love
talking to you I'm so happy you're
Nashville it's such a fun city and y'all
Christie's new single talking to God is
out now and expect more music for her
this year I'm very excited about hearing
it and remember to check out her stylish
affordable clothing for plus-sized women
at wall
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going